[Music]
welcome to the drama behind the scene
show I'm your host definition aka the
lord of leaks breaker of nudes and it
looks like george RR martin has spoken
out about his feelings towards the game
of thrones TV series and how it derailed
the books the author of the Song of Ice
and Fire recently spoke with newspaper
The Guardian on how the show had heard
the books rather than help them Game of
Thrones is of course infamous for
finishing the storyline before Martin
was able to wrap up the source material
and this is often cited as a criticism
to why many think that season 8 felt so
untrue to the original works I recently
covered Kevin Hart's thoughts on this
and he said that HBO should have let him
finish the work before adapting it but I
guess we can't turn back the clock and
nobody has the foresight that bran aka
the king of the Seven Kingdoms say that
with a serious face anyway in the
interview when discussing the show and
the books and how they matched up Martin
said the following there were a couple
of years where if I could have finished
the book I could have stayed ahead of
the show for another couple of years and
the stress was enormous I don't think it
was very good for me because the very
thing that should have speeded me up
actually slowed me down every day i sat
down to write and even if I had a good
day and a good day for me is three or
four pages I'd feel terrible because I'd
be thinking my god I have to finish the
book I've only written four pages when I
should have written about 40 but having
the show finishes freeing because I'm at
my own pace now I have good days and I
have bad days and the stress is far less
although it's still there I'm sure that
when I finish a dream of spring you'll
have to tether me to the earth when
discussing the similarities of the show
and book he stated they're not the same
thing although they are very closely
related to each other
does the show change the ending of the
books no it doesn't it doesn't change my
mind at all as Rick Nelson in garden
party one of my
favorite song says you can't please
everybody so you've gotta please
yourself acknowledging that the books
have changed his life Martin was then
asked if he missed the old days before
they became a worldwide phenomenon and
he said the following yeah honestly I do
I mean I can't go into a bookstore
anymore and that used to be my favorite
thing to do in the world to go in and
wonder from stack to stack take down
some books read a little leave with a
big stack of things I'd never heard of
when I came in now when I go to a book
store I get recognized within ten
minutes and there's a crowd around me so
you gain a lot but you also lose things
he agrees however that the end of the
series has relieved a great deal of
pressure and overall the fact that it
has ended has now allowed him to work at
his own pace and finish the storyline in
his own time actually really appreciate
that more has come forward and flat-out
said that the show wasn't really good
for him because that season a yeah it
wasn't really good for anyone was it I'm
kidding I'm good I'll stop beating a
dead horse anyway those who've watched
my Kevin Hart video will know that in
that I discussed how when properties are
sold on to TV studios they often lose
the creator's control and this can send
them while the into new directions which
I think in this interview modern AG
knowledge ease and discusses how there's
almost a regret around making a show
because it's stifled his creativity and
ultimately affected his life on the
other hand though you could argue that
should be grateful for the fact that his
work is now so beloved and he should
appreciate the love that his fans have
for it I kind of get the feeling that
during the recent interviews he's been
trying to distance himself from the show
and the Guardian author actually noted
before the interview that they were
asked not to discuss anything about
season a though this did inevitably come
up to shame because I think the work may
always have this cloud over it and now I
pretty much love the TV series up until
the last three hours of its run I think
the legacy that it created will always
be a point of contention with Martin's
work these interviews sort of come
across as if he's almost closing the
chapter on the show and gearing up to
present the real Game of Thrones
though if the book ever materializes is
another question it's definitely an
interesting debate that brings up a lot
of questions around how you can't put
the toothpaste back in the tube and
trying to started it's difficult to stop
it I really do wish that Martin had the
time to finish the books but I can
understand why HBO were anxious to keep
their money coming in and to make sure
that fans weren't waiting too long in a
perfect world that's what we would have
gotten but at least in some form or
another we will probably get an
interesting wrap-up to the story with
Martin's depiction obviously I loved
hear your thoughts on this story I'm
sure everyone is mixed opinions so make
sure that you leave them in the comment
section below if you enjoyed this video
then please like it and make sure you
check out my full breakdown of the
real-life serial killers of mine hunter
which will be linked at the end I go
over the true cases and people that made
it to the show so it's definitely worth
watching if you want to know more you
want to come talk to me about movies TV
shows games and comic books then you can
follow me on twitter at definition
whitey
it's the best way to get in touch with
me and it's the perfect place to suggest
new videos and content I also just want
to let you know that we're giving away a
free copy of John with curry on blu-ray
and all you have to do to be in with a
chance of winning is to like this video
make sure that you subscribe to the
channel and leave your thoughts on
Martin's comments in the comment section
below
but it'll be chosen at random on
September the 10th and the blu-ray will
be shipped out from then to ever get
surprised
so best of luck to everyone who takes
part this is the channel for people who
are never missing television so if
that's the kind of thing you like you
need to subscribe to definition thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
you've been the best and I'll see you
next time take care peace
[Music]
[Music]